[Music]
tm maury hardrake is shutting down hopes
for a sister-sister reboot never gonna
get it never gonna get it never gonna
get it never gonna get it never gonna
get it
the actress set the record straight on
tick tock hopping on the questions i get
asked trend to share the news after
clarifying that she wouldn't return for
the game reboot near when i lied
i will always love you hey
and wasn't thinking about having more
kids
[Music]
she answered the major question sister
sister fans been dying to know
[Music]
yep it's a no for tia i never want to
see your ugly face again then don't look
in the mirror tia and her twin sister
tamara mowry housley start on the hit
sitcom which aired from 1994 to 1999.
it's so much fun especially to work with
your sister i know that we did we did
guest spots and she wasn't there and i
was lonely but
hey t is here right by my side sister
sister followed the twins as they
reunited 14 years after being separated
at birth and moved in together blending
their families
mom
that girl has my face and fans have
longed for a reboot for the 90s series
for a while
before tia officially squashed the
reboot rumors she revealed to et in 2019
that the potential follow-up series was
being stopped by certain legalities
it was full steam ahead that it was
going to happen but then what was the
delay it was rights there were some
issues with rights
um that's so unfortunate which i know
because we didn't
we didn't wait for that because we were
like let's just go ahead let's go and
you know it'll be easy once we get to
all that it'll work itself out and
unfortunately it just didn't so my point
is it's it's completely out of our
control
as to why the sister sister reunion or
reboot did not happen but like i said
that doesn't mean that my sister and i
will never work again we always have
something up under our you know our
sleeves uh we've always got something we
do we do and and and fans can sleep well
at night knowing you guys are
you're down yeah
yes and we're we're we're working on it
and you know whatever happens happens
but last year her sister tamara said
they haven't given up on the idea it
seriously depends on timing
and
uh
i think the creative idea of it the
creative sister sister was such a
classic
like it's like if you're going to redo
goonies you have to make sure it's on
point
same thing with sister's sister so i can
tell you this if there is a reboot in
any kind of way a movie a series or
whatever it's going to be awesome
and i'd rather it be that and jack a
harry who played lisa landry talked
about what it might take to get the ball
rolling again there seems to be some
sort of a roadblock um i don't know a
missing puzzle piece that we can't you
know fully get sister sister 2020 or
2021 off the ground are you gonna help
the girls you know try to figure this
out
yeah but they're the leaders they
they're gonna lead and they're they're
having meetings so we'll see but it
might have to do with who owns it who
owns you know who
you know all that business sometimes the
vault is not open you know what i mean
sure
right away yeah uh do you know what the
status is or or what it will take in
order to get a little bit of movement
no i don't but they'll they'll keep me
posted but um i have an idea but i don't
really know so i don't want to say i
don't get no trouble
okay we'll keep our fingers crossed
you